bonsoir heureux de vous retrouver pour
une nouvelle édition du 78 lactu en ce
10 septembre 2013 voici les titres qui
seront développés ce soir lesépreuve de
la rue pour le projet de réforme des
retraites appel à la grève des
principaux syndicats et mobilisation à
Paris notamment le bilan de cette
journée au côté d'une délégation
évelinoise le texte de la réforme sera
présenté le 18 septembre en conseil des
ministres mobilisation également
aujourd'hui à l'école Jean-Baptiste
corau de maniléameau les parents
dénoncent un effectif trop important et
demande l'ouverture d'une 4e classe
politique et l'UDI qui s'organise pour
les prochaines élections municipales et
européennes à travers la voix de sa
section jeune dans le département
plusieurs opérations organisé en ce mois
de septembre avant l'université de
rentrer de la formation dans quelques
jours à Poitier le responsable jeunu des
des idé zvelin sera sur ce plateau à la
fin de ce journal mais pour débuter
cette édition préparée par la rédaction
et comme chaque soir l'image
d'aujourd'hui ce sont ces écoles fermées
ce matin dans plusieurs communes en
raison de la mobilisation contre la
réforme des retraites ici à La Verrière
les écoles du bois de l'éant des Noé
n'assuré ni la restauration scolaire ni
l'accueil du matin ni même les
animations du soir à l'échelle du
département la grève est moins suivi
même si le rectorat n'a pas encore
communiqué l'ensemble des chiffres mais
un autre exemple à Versailles où la
ville n'annoncait qu'une perturbation de
la cantine tout en prévoyant d'assurer
aux familles un repas froid et cette
mobilisation justement entre 300000 et
500000 personnes dans les rues dans
l'ensemble du territoire français selon
la CGT nous étions à Paris au côté de la
délégation ivelinoise reportage de cler
Cambier d'éodimoine c'était au milieu de
l'après-midi
N une bonne retraite n'est pas
compatible avec la réforme annoncée par
le gouvernement 43 ans de cotisation des
2035 et une hausse des cotisation à
l'appel des syndicats CGT FO su et
solidaire des manifestations ont lieu ce
mardi partout en France les délégations
ivelinois se sont rendu à Paris se
battre aujourd'hui pour la défense de
nos retraites c'est se battre pour nos
conditions de travail c'est se battre
pour nos droits c'est se battre pour le
pour le le plein emploi c'est se battre
pour l'avenir des jeunes pour la
sécurité et la survie des des salariés
et des retraités actuels quoi à cette
manifestation que l'on annonceit peu
suivie les syndicat comptabilisé de 300
à 500000 personnes sur la France l'enjeu
est faire pression avant le débat
parlementaire qui doit avoir lieu début
octobre autre revendication aujourd'hui
celle des parents d'élèves de l'école
Jean-Baptiste corau ils occupent depuis
le début de la semaine l'établissement
pour obtenir à l'ouverture d'une
nouvelle classe trop d'élèves par
professeur c'est le mot d'ordre comme
ils l'ont expliqué à Anthony rche et
Jonathan
villman depuis lundi les parents
d'élèves de l'école Jean-Baptiste corau
occupent l'établissement pour obtenir
une 4e classe les professeurs gèrent
plus de 30 enfants chacun en tant que
parents d'élèves nous trouvons que c'est
que c'est trop les conditions de travail
pour les enseignants deviennent très
difficiles les conditions
d'apprentissage du coup pour nos enfants
deviennent aussi très difficiles je ne
suis pas enseignante mais bon j'ai du
mal à imaginer comment un enseignant
peut faire une classe correcte avec des
petits on est en maternelle avec 34
enfants pour l'instant 96 enfants sont
scolarisés à l'école Jean-Baptiste corau
cette année mais la grille
départementale fixe un minimum de 98
élèves pour l'ouverture d'une classe
supplémentaire je pense que que le
directeur académique ne prendra pas de
décision d'ouverture de de classe si la
situation reste la même là j'ai vu trois
classes qui qui finalement fonctionnent
plutôt bien les parents ont reçu ce
mardi matin le soutien du maire de
manilé Bertrand Ouillon l'assure la
ville attend le feu vert de l'p
académique avec impatience c'est une
école qui de toute façon est faite pour
accueillir quatre classes donc toutes
les voilà le mobilier est prêt au
service technique dès qu'on a
l'autorisation tout est prêt le
lendemain on peut ouvrir dans l'attente
d'une réponse positive de l'inspection
académique les parents d'élèves de
l'école Jean-Baptiste cor entendent bien
continuer l'occupation de
l'établissement jusqu'à ce
vendredi pour sa campagne de
communication 2013 le Téléton a décidé
cette année de mettre en avant cinq
familles touchées par la maladie parmi
elles Luc Vanessa et leur fils thbao ils
sont ivelinois installés à Triel sursène
sur cette affiche Tibo 5 ans et son père
avec cette phrase mon fils est enfermé
dans un corset 7 jours sur 7 mon combat
lui offrir une vie normale Tibao souffre
d'amyotrophie spinale une maladie qui
détruit progressivement ses muscles mais
qui pour l'instant ne l'empêche pas de
suivre une scolarité normale le Téléton
se déroulera les 6 et 7 décembre
prochain il est bien sûr possible de
faire un don tout au long de l'année la
adresse du site internet de
l'Association Française contre les
myopathie elle s'affiche sur votre écran
un printemps plusveux mais en été radieu
les beaux jours de juillet août ont
permis aux commerçants de voir leur
bilan en hausse même si globalement les
touristes ont préféré les loisirs
extérieurs au musée yolè Torz pour les
précisions avec la météo mossade du mois
de juin la saison avait mal commencé les
touristes ont attendu l'arrivée des
beaux jours de juillet pour sortir de
chez eux bilan de la période dans le
départ
7 à 10 % d'augmentation par rapport à
l'été dernier tout site confondu les
gens prennent des vacances de plus en
plus courtes alors forcément un
département que nous sommes qui est un
département de loisir en bénéficie et
puis les Parisiens par exemple qui ont
pas envie de faire beaucoup de de de
voitures viennent chez nous c'est assez
dépaysan c'est pas loin et c'est même
accessible si on souhaite en transport
en commun en tête des sites touristiques
le château de Versailles les entrées ont
progressé de pour sur les mois de
juillet et août par rapport à la saison
dernière l'autre star de l'été c'est le
château de Breteuil plus 20 % cette
année avec 12000 visiteurs en juillet
les musées en revanche ont enregistré
une légère baisse de fréquentation un
petit point noir est à noter aussi du
côté des hôtels qui tournent surtout
grâce aux affaires la saison estivale
est toujours plus compliquée pour
l'hôtellerie puceque il y a moins de
réunion d'affaires et puis on assiste là
la crise on l' on l'a subi hein pour
l'hôtellerie on assiste vraiment à un
développement des fréquentations dans
les deux étoiles et moins dans le 3 et 4
les gens dépensent un petit peu moins
les responsables du tourisme insiste
dans l'ensemble la saison reste bonne en
attendant les chiffres précis on peut
d'ors et déjà affirmer que le
département a fait mieux que l'année
dernière il avait reçu plus de 2
millions et demi de
touristes 2e édition de l'opération
parole de jardinier qui est lancé dans
le département jusqu'à la fin du mois de
septembre une visite exceptionnelle des
jardins de Versailles avait lieu ce
dimanche en d'Alain Baraton le jardinier
en chef il a livré des secrets parfois
assez croustillant Catherine zulato et
clair
Cambier Alain Baraton presque comme un
roi ce dimanche dans les allées de
Versailles le jardinier en chef à
l'allure altière l'homme aime partager
les secrets de son domaine disons les
petits secrets marieanttoinette aimait
s'amuser dans cette grotte on dit même
que c'est ici qu'elle rencontrait
secretement devant un public forcément
comblé le jardinier en chef excellent
orateur C SC le RO Louis X opéré est en
convalescence à saécole chez les sœurs
lul lu compose une musique musique
quelques temps plus tard
el le musicien du roi George i
l'Angleterre de passage à versaill
entend la musique de lul et apprend les
paroles de de Mademoiselle de Brinon il
retourne en Angleterre avec Gods the
King et bien oui God the King a donc été
créé à Versailles pour la Fule du roi
onut
les angis et question musique Alain
Baraton en connaît un rayon pour les
amateurs de contrepéri il reprend cette
air bien connu qui met en scène un curé
Il court il court le furet je vous
laisse deviner le sens de la phrase
c'est une époque où quand on ne peut pas
trop parler on raconte et dites-vous
bien que chaque fois que vous avez
appris une chanson ancienne il y a
souvent beaucoup de connotations un peu
douteuses par exemple au clair de la
lune mon ami Pierre
et bien écoutez donc les paroles de
cette chanson qui date de
1792 quand vous apprenez que la voisine
fait briquet allez donc vous renseigner
sur le terme de briquet et vous
comprendrez qu'on vous a appris des
saloperies
à on a retenu des intrigues des
intrigues
amoureuses qu'onimagine pas forcément
comme quoi comme quoi comme le petit
cabanon de jardin le pavillon la
française fait qui servait qui servait
évidemment au roi on a une vision une
notre vision de Versailles avec les
commentaires qu'on a eu sur cette visite
là on voit les les jardins autrement et
on voit l'histoire autrement j'aime bien
parmi toutes les anecdotes rappeler
l'histoire ou les origines de la
construction du château ou du Petit
Trianon et j'ai rappelé par exemple que
le Petit Trianon ce matin avait été
construit non pas pour permettre à Louis
XV d'être au plus près des savants qui
viennent travailler la botanique dans ce
lieu mais pour permettre à Madame de
Pompadour de s'accaparer pour elle seul
le roi et éviter qu'il ne se disperse
trop dans le lit de quelques court au
château un un jardin ne peut pas être
beau ne peut pas transmettre une émotion
si on n'est pas capable de connaître son
histoire et son parcours une visite
exceptionnelle et pleine d'esprit dans
le cadre de la 2uxe édition de parole de
jardinier Alain Baraton en est le Parin
une visite ponctuée donc d'anecdote
privée mais qui ne fait pas oublier la
magnificence de Versailles en matière de
jardin le domaine en toute humilité ce
sont 43 km d'allée 350000 arbres et 1
million et demi de fleurs la la petite
et la grande histoire ne peuvent être
ici que des
mesures on passe à l'invité de cette
édition Antoine B bonsoir bonsoir vous
êtes le responsable udi jeune dans le
département des yelines on va parler de
la rentrée politique de votre formation
et puis aussi de cette déclaration
conjointe avec les jeunes modem du
département vous avez annoncé prendre
acte du rapprochement entre vos deux
formations lancé par Jean-Louis borlau
notamment une main tendue à François
Beyrou pour les européennes pourquoi
cette maintendue on imaginait plutôt les
deux formations on va dire peut-être
fâché en tout cas de ad l'UDI é en plus
porté vers un soutien à l'UMP et puis le
modem un soutien à François Hollande ça
a été le cas pendant l'entre de tour de
la présidentielle aujourd'hui pourquoi
cette mentendu tout simplement je pense
pour une question de cohérence politique
aujourd'hui les projets sont censés nous
rapprocher on se bat pour les mêmes
projets Politique et c'est en ce sens
qu'à priori il nous paraissait plus
logique avec Antonin en tout cas de de
faire ce communiqué Antonin gr c'est le
président des Jeunes modem dans le
département il est en ligne avec nous ce
soir Bonsoir à vous bonsoir est-ce que
vous avez tout simplement entendu
Antoine B le responsable udi dans le
département lui il dit qu'il est normal
de voir les deux formations se
rapprocher c'est votre sentiment
également c'est c'est normal et c'est
nécessaire je je pense qu'on a des
projets similaires et la même envie de
voir une Europe bien construite et une
Europe qui va de l'avant je je considère
que c'est nécessaire que nous aillonss
ensemble vers vers ces élections alors
comment vous expliquez alors vous parlez
des élections européennes que on puisse
assister à un rapprochement pour les
européennes malgré les différences que
j'exposaé tout à l'heure entre l'UMP le
soutien au PS côté côté modem pourquoi
un rapprochement pour les européennes et
on en parle beaucoup moins pour les
municipales par exemple je vous pose la
question tout d'abord à vous antoréet
puis ensuite Antoine B pourra réagir
d'accord je je pense qu'il faut pas être
sectaire vous vous parliz des élections
présidentielles je voudrais juste
rappeler que le le modem n'a pas appelé
à voter François Hollande c'est François
bayarou qui a donné sa déclaration
personnelle Françis berou qui son
Françis berou qui est quand même le
responsable du MoDem on peut jouer sur
les mots effectivement mais
il n'appellerit pas à voter il pense que
chaque individu est capable de faire sa
propre décision de prendre son choix euh
nous ne sommes pas secteur nous
considérons que en fonction des projets
en fonction de ce qui est proposé il
faut aller avec le le le meilleur projet
systématiquement je pense qu'avec l'UDI
on sera capable de faire un projet
européen commun qui sera cohérent et qui
qui donnera envie aux citoyens d'aller
de l'avant mais pas un projet commun
pour pour les municipales à mon avis les
municipales ça prendra
alors on va laisser tout d'abord
répondre le responsable du DI et puis je
vous laisserai réagir ensuite je pense
que pour les municipal c'est une
question aussi locale donc il faut
laisser les hommes décider aussi de ce
qui se passe au niveau local c'est une
question d'homme c'est une question plus
particulière aujourd'hui c'est vrai que
vous l'avez rappeler les histoires sont
différentes pour le modème et l'UDI il
faudra certainement un peu un peu plus
de temps pour une alliance systématique
à tous les échelon cependant
effectivement les européensnes sont un
projet commun assez évident il me semble
pour les centristes de cœur européiste
par nature et en ce sens c'est à mon
avis le premier échelon qu'il faudra
mettre sur table al il y a tout même je
veux pas insister sur ces divisions
entre les deux parties mais il y a eu
quelques déclarations depuis cette
tentative de rapprochement entre les
deux formations Hervé Morin qui demande
à François berou de clarifier sa ligne
politique et puis de l'autre côté c'est
le vice-président du MoDem Jean-Luc
benamias qui demande à l'UDI de renoncer
à une alliance exclusive avec l'UMP
alors c'est difficile tout de même d'y
voir clair peut-être aussi pour les
électeurs Antoon
inré je je pense qu'il faut pas imaginer
que les électeurs ne soient pas capables
de comprendre les les les tiraillements
qui peuvent exister la la la politique
française est difficile dans ce sens
qu'elle oblige pour avoir de bons
résultats à s'allier et de préférence
avec les plus gros alors ça a toujours
été le choix facile de s'allier avec le
plus gros le plus proche pour avoir un
maximum de voix nous on a choisi le
chemin de l'indépendance l'UDI a choisi
un autre chemin mais ne souhaite pas non
plus se faire fagocité par
l'UMP j'attends de voir comment ça va se
former alors vous justement vous
demandez quoi à l'UDI vous demandez
aussi que l'UDI prenne cette distance
avec l'UMP que ce soit
clair je pense que pour un rapprochement
aux élections européennes il est évident
que nous ne pouvons pas modem UMP et udi
y aller ensemble ça sera soit les partis
centristes soit l'UDI avec l'UMB Antoine
B vous partagez cette opinion justement
sur ce principe là je suis assez
d'accord et pour l'instant d'après les
dire de nos aînés c'est le chemin qui
est suivi aujourd'hui la semaine
dernière pardon la réunion des Européens
à la Maison de la Chimie de l'UDI prenez
clairement ce chemin là je vous poser
autrement la question est-ce que les
députés européens des différentes
formations centristes en tout cas les
Français qui les représentants français
n'ont pas peur de perdre leur poste
aussi et c'est pour ça qu'il y a cette
alliance un moment il faut aussi savoir
se battre pour ces principes Jean-Lou le
borleau l'a rappelé clairement il y a
pas très longtemps aujourd'hui on se bat
pour un projet européen et pas pour des
ambitions personnelles vous restez en
ligne avec nous Anton INR je vous
propose d'écouter un micro trottoir que
nous avons réalisé aujourd'hui nous
sommes allés demander aux citoyens aux
électeur quelle différence il faisait
entre le modem et l'UDI écoutez pour moi
c'est exactement les mêmes je vois pas
de différence pour moi c'est les mêmes
idées les même c'est les mêmes quoi je
dirais qu'il y en a un le chef a une
plus grande gueule que l'autre quoi mais
bon c'est tout je vois pas trop de
différence au niveau politique c'est des
centristes je vois pas beaucoup de
différ ils sont issus à peu près de la
même
idéologie moi je trouve que c'est bien
qu'il se qu'il se rassemble pour pour
avoir un peu plus de de poids vis-à-vis
des des gros
buldooser la différence c'est que borlau
il est plus du côté de l'UMP et que
berou il se dissocie de l'UMP il est
plus c'est un
centriste catholique pour moi ce sont
des parties qui sont sensiblement
identique c'est ce qu'on a entendu tout
à l'heure je vous fais réagir tout
d'abord Antoine B c'est à priori ce que
défendent aussi nos aînés effectivement
c'est ce que disait je crois berou il y
a pas très longtemps les centr c'est la
seule famille où on est tous d'accord
sur le projet mais où les familles sont
divisées alors que effectivement les
division existe sur le plan des idées au
autres dans les autres parties et
pourtant il arrivve à être ensemble donc
nous c'est justement le le chemin qu'on
doit parcourir aujourd'hui c'est
effectivement se retrouver se retrousser
les manches et se battre ensemble pour
nos projets commun et Anto inré pour
conclure lorsque vous entendez dans le
micro trottoir que je vais reprendre les
mots de cette téléspectatrice qu'on a
interviewé cet après-midi il y a un des
deux chefs qui a une plus grande gueule
qu'un autre vous vous dites que au bout
d'un moment il y a un des deux hommes
qui va devoir s'effacer pour fédérer les
centristes vous voyez très bien que
alors déjà ces hommes se connaissent
bien et travaill ensemble depuis très
longtemps et on n'est pas dans un combat
deschef on est dans dans un combat de
stratégie politique fr jean-l blot ne
doivent s'effacer les deux peuvent
cohabiter je pense qu'ils peuvent non
seulement cohabiter mais il déjà fait
par le passé ils ont travaillé ensemble
lors de campagnees présidentiell par le
passé ils sont habitués à travailler
ensemble c'est pas une question de
s'effacer vous savez c'est une question
de travailler ensemble pour représenter
un maximum nos idées et et notre projet
pour la France et pour l'Europe donc il
y aura une mobilisation en vue des
européenne merci d'avoir été en ligne
avec nous ce soir pour les jeunes modemd
ziveline le responsable jeune udi va
rester avec nous sur ce plateau on va se
pencher aussi sur le reste de votre
actualité en cette rentrée politique
notamment l'opération OnField elle a été
lancé durant l'été à l'initiative de
militant soutenue par l'UDI à travers la
France ce weekend une escale était
prévue à trappe devant le forum des
associations vous étiez présent on
regarde ce reportage de la rédaction ici
pas de logo de l'UDI mais un rhinocéros
blanc sur fond bleu un symbole imposant
pour cette opération permettant d'aller
à la rencontre de la population baptisée
Enfield et ce jour-là installé à trappe
c'est pourtant bien le parti de
Jean-Louis borlau qui se cache derrière
ce slogan à la politique comme vous ne
l'aviez jamais vu on n'est pas là pour
recruter on n pas venu pour parler de
nous on est venu pour parler des
Français donc on cherche on ne cherche
pas à en faire des centristes pas du
tout en fait on essaie simplement de
recueillir leurs avis concrètement ça se
traduit ainsi les volontaires du projet
unfield partout en France dans plusieurs
villes en fait vont sur le terrain
donnent la parole au français sont à
leur écoute et en fait recueillent leurs
doléances leurs avis leurs impressions
leurs ressentis de la vie politique
française actuelle l'opération lancée
durant l'été a déjà fait escale à
Marseille Nant ou encore leement les
militants parlent de succès et ont
décidé de pour suivre l'action jusqu'au
début de l'automne c'est très bien voilà
il faut faut dire son opinion de toute
façon je vois pas pourquoi on naurait
pas droit on aura le droit de cacher ce
qu'on pense voilà j'espère que
sincèrement après ce petit ces petites
rencontre le gouver le gouvernement
pourra voir les choses différemment des
inquiétudes qui seront regroupées dans
un cahier de doléance et diffusé aux
élus locaux mais qui serviront aussi
sans doute à alimenter les futurs
programmes des candidats udi aux
européennes et aux municipales on vient
de vous voir présent sur cette cette
opération attrape très clairement
pourquoi ne pas vous présenter sous les
couleurs de l'UDI c'est soutenu par
l'UDI mal tout vous êtes des militants
udi il faut l'assumer pourquoi vous
l'assumez pas c'est pas une question
d'assumer on l'assume tout à fait quand
on nous pose la question on répond nous
sommesist question quand on vous pose la
question oui bien sûr alors pourquoi
effectivement tout simplement parce que
les gens ont une défiance de plus en
plus grande n de plus en plus grande à
l'égard des politiques et aujourd'hui
pour recueillir l'avis des Français
vis-à-vis de ce système politique global
que ce soit au niveau local ou national
il nous a il on on s'est aperçu
effectivement qu' était plus simple
d'aller à la rencontre des gens sans
afficher effectivement d'étiquettes
politiqu électeurs sont pas naïf pour
autant ils vont se rendre compte que
finalement c'est sous couvert d'un d'un
nom avec un logo de rhinoceros derrière
ce cache mais derrière on est pas là
pour vendre un discours on n'est pas là
pour donner des traacks di on ne vend
aucun aucune étiquette politique on
recueille simplement l' viis et les
sentiments des gens à l'égard de la
politique ça va servir à quoi à faire
des États généraux justement par exemple
pourquoi pas effectivement donc comme
vous l'avez dit effectivement on fera un
cahier de doléance à la fin du mois de
septembre que l'on transmettra aux
hommes politiques qui servir toutes les
formations politiques tout à fait ça
sera ouvert c'est vraiment le but de de
l'action c'est vraiment recueillir le
sentiment des Français à l'égard de la
politique c'est pas faire de la
politique politicienne c'est renouer le
contact et le dialogue qui s'est perdu
aujourd'hui malgré tout ça va servir
forcément à préparer le programme des
municipales voir même des européennes
pour l'UDI c'est P qui sont programme
puisquen fait les gens nous n donne pas
nécessairement des des sentiments
extrêmement précis sur tel ou tel sujet
local c'est une question de ressentiment
c'est savoir comment on fait de la
politique comment on fera de la
politique demain et pour les militants
jeunes comme nous c'est extrêmement
important on n'est pas là simplement à
prendre la température à l'égard des
Français sur le papier on va à leur
rencontre on cherche à les comprendre et
donc ensuite ça servira à élaborer un
programme parce que c'est bien de les
écouter mais il faut leur proposer des
choses éid bien évidemment donc
finalement ça servira aussi à l'UDI pour
pour préparer son programme lui dit à
tous les hommes engagés femmes et hommes
engagés vous serez candidat vous-même
pour les municipales dans le
départementésement à virofl à viroflé
donc c'est pas àod voilà lorsque vous
écoutez les revendications ça vous
permettra aussi de proposer des choses
pour C éction sûr bien sûr mais comme
toute homme et toute femme qui ira sur
notre site OnField qui est accessible à
tout le monde ouvert à tout le monde et
toutes les personnes intéressées par ce
sujetl par ce projet là pourront avoir
accès aux informations au français pr
sur le site que justement c'est soutenu
par l'UDI tout à fait transparent
prochaine réunion de ce type prochaine
opération de ce type dans le département
c'est à Versailles le 28 septembre 14 15
septembre à Poitier journée de rentrée
de l'UDI l'ordre du jour c'est de savoir
comment se positionner par rapport au
modem c'est de savoir quelle distance ou
non prendre avec l'UMP de faire le point
de cette opération de fil il y aura une
réflexion sur le plan idéologique c'est
certain mais c'est avant tout se réunir
se regrouper c'est la première
université d'été qui aura lieu pour
l'UDI je rappelle que c'est un par parti
qui est tout jeune qui a à peine un an
d'existence donc il faut aussi réunir la
famille et et se retrouver tous ensemble
justement partie très jeune on peut
faire un point sur les adhésions dans le
département par exemple aussi bien l'UDI
que les jeunes udi sur le département
moi je peux difficilement vous le dire
parce que j'ai pas les chiffres en main
mais je sens clairement au niveau des
adhésions au niveau des gens que j'ai de
plus en plus en contact que c'est un
parti qui qui intéresse les gens et les
jeunes aussi les jeunes surtout vous
êtes combien au sein des jeunes
aujourd'hui en terme d'adhésion nous
sommes une cinquantaine après de jeunes
actif on est plus autour de la vingtaine
mais c'est en progression nette de
semaine en semaine et de mois en mois et
23 septembre pour conclure avec cette
rentrée politique de l'UDI des jeunes
udi il y aura une réunion les jeunes en
politique c'est le thème d'une
discussion qui aura lieu à Fontenel
fleur tout à fait qui sera présent et
alors nous avons invité Mar de gererm
maire de Marmagne président UD du Cher
qui a été maire à l'âge de 27 ans donc
il pourra nous raconter un peu son
parcours et la façon dont il est arrivé
à ce stade là nous aurons également Rami
notre coordinateur national chez les
jeunes udi qui viendra nous expliquer
l'investissement politique au niveau des
jeunes au niveau national donc ça sera
un échelon autre et nous aurons
également Flavien bazenet qui était
candidat aux dernières législatives et
qui sera candidat au municipal à J en
Josas merci à vous d'être venu ce soir
sur le plateau du 78 lactu vous êtes le
responsable du DI jeune dans le
département des ivelines juste un point
sur cette mobilisation du jour contre
les retraites pour vous donner ce
chiffre c'est le chiffre du ministère de
l'Intérieur au niveau national 155000
manifestants contre environ entre 300000
et 500000 selon la CGT qui organisit
cette mobilisation contre les retraite
voilà pour ce point sur l'actualité du
jour c'est la fin de cette édition du
Journal du 10 septembre je vous retrouve
demain pour l'essentiel de l'information
locale les programmes se poursuivent sur
TVfil 78 avec notamment le 78 société
rendez-vous bimensuel présenté par
Catherine zulato elle débattra cette
fois-ci avec ses invités des questions
de la citoyenneté et des incivilités
excellente soirée